what's your motivation it's important to
understand the motivation behind every
action that you take as an entrepreneur
because there's going to be one or two
things one you're doing it because you
really love to do it and it's the right
thing to do and the other reason too is
because
you think it's going to help your
business and make some money
and sometimes they work together but a
lot of times they don't and here's the
challenge okay the challenge is giving
up on things that
you think will make a lot of money you
think could work for you but you don't
enjoy because if you can't give yourself
fully to a task fully to a project fully
to an idea it's not going to work it can
work for other people but it's not going
to work for you and that takes a lot of
courage and guts to give up on those
projects that you see working for
everybody else
but it will not work for you let me give
you an example i look at my use of
twitter and twitter i love twitter i
love twitter it's a way to connect with
people i share
my videos i share quotes i share
pictures i share what's happening in my
life i love twitter and i love
interacting with you guys
and i came up with an idea hey what if i
made a twitter list of all the media who
are covering entrepreneurship the big
media
and i read their articles and i comment
on it and i tweet on it
and so i built this list
and
and i started following them and i
started responding to them and what they
were posting
and after a few days it started to feel
like a chore
it started to feel like a chore this
wasn't something i enjoyed doing and i
thought wow this this could be a great
idea you know my end goal was to be in
the media more so i was hoping that if
somebody you know saw my tweets enough
and i was leaving insightful comments
they would write to me and i would be an
expert on one of their columns and that
works that works for a lot of people
the problem is i didn't enjoy doing it
if you're the person who reads an
article and you look at it and say wow
that is so great i have to leave a
comment on i have to let everybody know
about it or you read an article and
you're like that was terrible this is so
wrong i need to leave a comment and say
why
then that's a good strategy for you i'm
not that guy
i don't enjoy doing that stuff so i had
to kill the strategy even though
it works for other people this isn't an
easy thing it's a constant daily
struggle because we're all trying to
think hey how do we grow our businesses
what can i do today to grow my business
today right i want to make some more
money i want to bring in you know more
people i want to have a greater impact
what can i do today to make that happen
and we look for easy solutions and we
look for things that work for other
people
we look for shortcuts you know we look
for ways to make it happen right now i
get it you're impatient right i'm
impatient too i want to hit my billing
entrepreneur goal as soon as possible
but the way that it's going to happen is
by doing things that you love and you
can pour yourself into you can give
yourself fully to
so one of the things that i do on
twitter and on on youtube is i respond
to everybody
right you leave a comment on my video or
you tweet me back unless you're spamming
me or bothering me i'm gonna respond to
you
and that takes time that takes time
every day
to do and i could give that as a
strategy to say hey here's what you need
to do you need to respond to everybody
who writes in the challenge is
you may not enjoy that
you know i
love you guys i love the youtube
community i love my twitter community
it's honestly one of the best parts of
my day i wake up i eat my lentils for
breakfast and i look at your comments
and i just start responding and it may
not be an in-depth comment i may just
leave a happy face whatever it is but i
am responding to people and i love doing
that so i need to keep doing it and i
need to have faith
i need to believe
that by doing that it's going to help my
business grow
and it has
it has grown i've gotten tons of
opportunities that have come from my
youtube channel and that's because you
guys watch and you guys share and you
guys leave comments
so you have to look at everything you're
doing with your business every task that
you're doing and you have to understand
is this something
that needs to be done and if it is
is it you who needs to do it
because you can always automate it you
can delegate it you can
eliminate it if it's not helpful
but you need to make sure that your time
is being spent on things that you love
doing things that you can pour yourself
into things that you can get lost in
things that you feel like you're in the
flow things that you look at the clock
at nine in the morning and suddenly at
six at night and you don't know where
the time went because you're so invested
in what you're doing that's what you
need to be spending your time on not the
things where you look at your calendar
of all the things you need to do like oh
i hate everything on my list
if you're that entrepreneur if you hate
everything that you have to do today
you're not going to achieve massive
success with your business it's not
going to happen because you're doing
things that you hate how can you have
great success when you're doing things
that you hate
so look at your schedule look at your
tasks look at what you have to do today
this week this month
and really examine it
are you doing these things because it's
the right thing to do because you love
it because you're fully invested in it
or are you doing it because you think
it's going to help grow your business
but deep down inside you really hate it
take a hard look
and start making some changes
believe for those of you watching like
the video
give a thumbs up below leave a comment
you know how much it means to me leave a
comment below you have a question for me
leave it below in the comment section
and if you want to see more videos like
this click on my face subscribe to the
channel and i'll see you soon